speaking of nick saban the guy who is
called nick from time to time
i continue to be fascinated
by
his
position
on the decision of the miami dolphins in
march 2006 to not sign
drew brees he talked about it again
yesterday and as we get farther and
farther removed from 2006
the story becomes more and more specific
on this point one
drew brees wanted to come to miami two
i nick saban wanted drew brees in miami
three
somebody else specifically a doctor kept
me from signing drew brees and now for
this is the news that that saban broke
with his most recent comments
once we didn't get drew brees i decided
i'm getting out of here
we're not going to be able to win
without a quarterback we were nine and
seven and on the brink of the playoffs
without a good quarterback we get drew
brees we go over the top and the moment
we didn't get drew brees i realize this
isn't for me i don't buy it
i don't buy it i think what nick saban
wants to do
he wants to rectify his failed nfl head
coaching career
with the very basic and simple argument
if they had just listened to me and
signed drew brees
we would have become the team since 2006
the saints became now my first problem
with that is
it really undermines the work that sean
payton did as coach the saints to get
the most out of drew brees brees was
part of it payton was part of it if
brees goes to miami and plays for saban
who's a defensive coach
who's going to get the most out of drew
brees is it going to work
in miami the way it worked in new
orleans saban just wants to assume
that drew brees wherever he would have
landed as of 2006 is going to unlock all
of these achievements and performances
that that made him one of the great
quarterbacks of all time i i don't know
that it's automatic
now now maybe it would have happened
everywhere else but i think we can't
underestimate the contribution to bree's
career that came from sean payton and
how those two together created a magical
outcome that that caused sustained
success
in new orleans
pretty much constantly since 2006 with
the exception of 2012 the bounty gate
year and then the effort to rebuild the
defense after the bounty gate year they
were still competitive
offensively
even when their defense was horrible
once the defense caught up you see what
they've done every year since 2017 2017
18 19 20 great teams in the regular
season and but for bad calls bad breaks
bad whatever may have been back to
another super bowl and
and that doesn't mean the dolphins would
have become that and that saban would
have been happy in miami and would have
been content to stay there year after
year
i think that in lieu of going back to
the nfl
and proving that he could thrive at that
level he just wants people to conclude
oh nick would have been good nick would
have won a super bowl he doesn't have to
go back and win one enough people are
going to believe nick would have won one
but my other concern
is this
and and it's it's funny to me that you
know nick saban a guy who always has to
control all aspects of a football
program he's willing to create the
impression that he really didn't control
the miami dolphins when we all know that
he did
the idea that one doctor
said we can't sign drew brees and that
nick saban didn't have the power or the
ability to overcome that doctor's
opinion tells me
that nick saban agreed with it because
if nick saban wanted drew brees there
drew brees would have been there
nick saban said yesterday that dr james
andrews who performed the operation on
drew brees shoulder said that he should
be fine okay
if you've got some sort of an internal
thing and you don't inherently have the
power to tell the doctor who said we
can't sign drew brees sit down and shut
up you're not paid for your opinions on
personnel matters we'll go forward thank
you for your medical advice but we know
what we're doing if he isn't able to do
that at a minimum what you do is you go
to wayne heizenga who was the owner of
the team at the time
and you bring
dr james andrews to miami
and you have andrews explain to heizenga
why andrews thinks that brees will be
fine because whoever the doctor is that
said no
chances are wayne heisenga is going to
listen to dr james andrews and say yes
and at the end of the day
i don't think there's any dispute
heising is the ultimate authority and if
you throw on top of it
saban's
position assuming that what he said
yesterday is true
that when they didn't sign brees that's
when he decided i'm getting out of here
well
if saban had said to wayne heizenga
look wayne i feel very strongly about
this
we need drew brees
i'm willing to take the risk james
andrews tells me he's going to be fine
and let me tell you this if we don't get
drew brees
i'm leaving after this year this is it
for me i mean if wayne heisenga knew
that of course he's going to sign drew
brees of course it's going to happen
because they still got a quarterback
they traded a second round pick for
dante culpepper they decided to take the
guy who was coming off of the serious
knee injury and give up a second round
pick over the guy who was coming off of
the shoulder injury
serious but still
rehabbing just like culpepper was
they could have had breeze
for no second round pick he was a free
agent they made that decision and the
idea that nick saban was just a
bystander while somebody else controlled
the decision i reject that
it goes against everything we've ever
known about nick saban he's not going to
take that if he wants brees he's getting
breeze and people ask why do you keep
talking about it because saban keeps
talking about it and the problem is
no one's in a position to call him out
about it at alabama because they don't
care it's 15 years ago but as long as he
keeps talking about it i'm gonna be here
to scrutinize what he has to say
and
and give you the audience the real truth
and the real truth is saban could have
had brees and i think saban still would
have left miami anyway possibly after
the 2006 season when alabama came
calling because of course i'm not going
to be the alabama coach which is what
satan said a few days before taking the
job
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports